hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live kein Wechsel sondern der neue alte
Präsident in der Türkei bleibt Recep
tahib Erdogan er hat die Stichwahl gegen
Herausforderer kilica Holo mit rund 52%
gewonnen gestern Abend schauen wir rein
in die Bilder in seiner Siegesrede vor
dem Präsidentenpalast behauptete Erdogan
der Türkei wurden viele Fallen gestellt
es wären schmutzige Spiele gegen sie
gespielt worden und er sagte deutsche
und französische Medien hätten
Schlagzeilen gemacht um sicherzustellen
dass er gestürzt werde
naja das ist nicht passiert wir haben es
gesehen erlebt er hat gewonnen und auch
hier bei uns in Deutschland war die
Zustimmung für ihn erneut groß jetzt
hier auch bei der Stichwahl stand
Auszählung letzte Nacht stimmten hier in
Deutschland rund 67% für Erdogan das
schreibt die staatliche
Nachrichtenagentur Anadolu
Regierungschefs aus aller Welt die haben
Erdogan bereits gratuliert aber zu
seinem Sieg hier in Deutschland gab es
auch scharfe Kritik so sagte
bundesakraminister Özdemir über die
Freuden feiern und autokorses die es gab
hier bei uns in Deutschland in der Nacht
sie sind eine nicht zu überhörende
absagern unsere pluralistische
Demokratie und Zeugnis unseres
Scheiterns unter ihnen und der
Vorsitzende der Europäischen Volkspartei
EVP Manfred Weber der forderte sogar den
EU-Beitrittsprozess mit der Türkei zu
beenden also diese Wahl die macht
Schlagzeilen heute deshalb ist sie bei
uns Thema was bedeuten fünf weitere
Jahre Erdogan für die Türkei also für
das Land selbst aber auch für die
Beziehung mit Europa das ist heute unser
Thema ihr könnt gerne mit kommentieren
live bei uns oder schreibt Fragen per
Mail beides möglich und wir wollen
gemeinsam mit euch das Ergebnis jetzt
analysieren denn bei uns ist jetzt
zuerst unser Korrespondent in der Türkei
in Ankara ist für uns Jörg braase hallo
hallo Jörg du hast die Rede gestern
Abend mit verfolgt was live dabei der
Ton der dort angeschlagen wurde ist der
altbekannt oder ist der jetzt noch
schärfer als zuvor
nein ich denke vor allem hat Recep
Tayyip Erdogan noch mal auch diese
durchaus kontroversen Positionen
wiederholt die er ja bereits im
Wahlkampf mehrfach angesprochen hat er
hat wieder die Opposition
angegriffen dafür dass sie angeblich
meteoristen paktiert der hat die habe
das schon
angesprochen und zitiert er hat
westliche Medien angegriffen die
Propaganda gegen ihn gemacht hätten aber
der Türkei sei es halt gelungen dem
Westen wieder mal eine Lektion zu
erteilen das ist natürlich eine
Botschaft an seine nationalistischen
Wähler wie man überhaupt sagen muss dass
er in dieser Wahl auch gerade im ersten
Wahlgang bei den Parlamentswahlen hat
man das gesehen nationalistischer
Parteien die eigentlichen Wahlgewinner
sind und an diese Klientel an diese
Wähler hat er dann diese Botschaft
gestern noch mal gerichtet ähm er hat
auch von perversen Tendenzen gesprochen
die die Opposition unterstützen würde
das ging dann gegen die lgbtqi Community
und das sind die Gruppen die er da
gestern auch noch mal angegriffen hat
insofern war das aber der Ton letztlich
den wir aus dem Wahlkampf schon von ihm
gewohnt waren es gab gestern Abend
einzelne Berichte dass es Angriffe
gegenüber wahlbeobachtenden gegeben
hätte war das jetzt heute auch noch mal
Thema oder waren das wirklich nur
einzelne Berichte
also das sind so weit wie das beurteilen
können einzelne Berichte es wird heute
Nachmittag eine Pressekonferenz geben
der OSZE Beobachter und der
Wahlbeobachter der Europäischen Union da
werden diese Vorfälle sicherlich noch
mal aufgelistet aber ich rechne
eigentlich nicht damit dass die Kritik
die wir dann sicherlich hören werden
über die hinaus geht die auch bereits
nach dem ersten Wahlgang geäußert wurde
wo es dann hieß ja es hat einzelne
Vorfälle gegeben Angriffe auf
Wahlbeobachter ist wurde einigen der
Zugang verwehrt es gab auch immer wieder
Berichte darüber dass teilweise
bewaffnete Sicherheitskräfte Polizisten
genannte Marie in den Wahllokalen selbst
anwesend waren Druck ausgeübt hätten auf
Wähler das werden wir sicherlich wieder
hören aber unterm Strich wird das Urteil
vermutlich lauten es gab diese Vorfälle
sie haben aber das Wahlergebnis im
Ganzen nicht verfällt
sprechen gleich weiter schauen aber
vorher zusammen in einen Bericht denn
unsere Kollegin Anna Feist die hat den
Abend und die Siegesrede von Erdogan
noch einmal zusammengefasst
trotz des trüben Wetters ist für mich
mit secin heute ein Freudentag sein
Präsident wurde wiedergewählt
dieser Mann braucht das Land nicht aber
das Land braucht ihn
es wirkt wie eine durchinierte Show die
Wahlnacht in der Türkei gestern Abend
gegen 19 Uhr Ortszeit noch sind nicht
alle Stimmen ausgezählt da meldet sich
Erdogan mit einer liebeshymne an sich
selbst wir lieben ihn wir lieben ihn
singt der Präsident und kürzt sich zum
Sieger darauf ein treues Schuhe ans Volk
wie wir euch seit 21 Jahren würde
erweisen werden wir das weiter tun und
werden euch dienen bis zum Tod
[Applaus]
dann aufgeputschte Anhänger in
Freudentaumel
wir haben wieder gewonnen egal was ihr
macht wir werden wieder gewinnen ich
kann gerade meine Gefühle nicht
beschreiben
ich bin sehr glücklich dabei ist ihr
Sieg knapper als erwartet Erdogan kommt
auf knapp über 50% der Rollo auf knapp
unter 50%
ins Parlament gewählt wurde die
kurdischen Stimmen sind entscheidend
trotzdem hat er sich anderen zugewandt
um nationalistische Stimmen zu gewinnen
tatsächlich zeigen die Zahlen das
Grillitsch der Rollo insbesondere in den
Kurdengebieten leichte Verluste
hinnehmen musste während Erdogan sogar
an Stimmen dazu gewonnen hat gegen 22
Uhr Ortszeit meldet sich der dann in
Ankara zu Wort mit einem
Erklärungsversuch der Niederlage
wir haben die unfairste Wahl der letzten
Jahre erlebt alle Staatsmittel wurden
nur für die Regierung ausgegeben und nur
für einen Mann mobilisiert
[Musik]
er werde trotzdem weiter kämpfen sagt er
geschlagene noch dann verlässt er so
schnell es geht den Saal während nur
wenige Kilometer weiter Erdogan vom
Balkon des Präsidialamtes vor das Volk
tritt mit einem scharfen Seitenhieb
gegen seine Kritiker
oh Mann der agileri deutsche
französische und englische Zeitungen
haben versucht Erdogan zu stürzen und
auch sie haben verloren
es gilt als wahrscheinlich dass der Kurs
der Türkei nun noch autoritärer wird
Menschenrechte und Pressefreiheit noch
stärker beschnitten werden
entscheidende Fehler gemacht das haben
wir eben im Beitrag gehört zuletzt hat
er versucht mit flüchtlingsfeindlichen
Sprüchen noch Stimmen für sich zu
gewinnen hat ihm das am Ende mehr
geschadet würdest du sagen Jörg
also das ist ja im Moment schwer zu
sagen ob ihm das geschadet hat wir haben
es ja gehört den Beitrag viele Kurden
haben gesagt dass sie nun das
Oppositionsbündnis nicht mehr wählen
könnten nachdem auch eine
nationalistische Partei umworben hat
insofern wird er auf der einen Seite ein
paar Stimmen gewonnen haben auf der
anderen Seite hat er sie verloren alles
in allem wird jetzt denke ich die
Diskussion innerhalb des
oppositionsbündnisses beginnen Optik da
Rollo tatsächlich der beste Kandidat
gewesen ist ich rechne schon damit dass
da jetzt eine Abrechnung gemacht wird in
den nächsten Tagen das ist da eventuell
auch zu personellen Änderungen kommen
könnte das muss man mal sehen der große
Schock das ist völlig klar den gab es
eigentlich nach dem ersten Wahlgang wo
die Opposition sich doch sehr viel mehr
erhofft hat und letztlich muss man sagen
dass das Ergebnis des ersten Wahlgangs
im zweiten Wahlgang ja wiederholt wurde
das ist also der Opposition dann in
diesen zwei Wochen auch nicht mehr
gelungen ist die Stimmen die sie noch
gebraucht hätten aufzuholen und was
erwartest du wie geht's weiter jetzt mit
Erdogans Kurs was hat er vor denn die
Probleme im Land sind ja groß also hohe
Inflation Wirtschaft geht nicht gut also
was wird da als erstes der angehen
müssen wie geht das weiter
also was man glaube ich gesehen hat über
die Jahre der Regierung Erdogan ist das
ja auf der einen Seite natürlich seine
Klientel mit mit markigen Sprüchen
versucht bei Laune zu halten was wir
sehen denke ich weil diese Koalition die
er da geschmiedet hat aus teilweise
extremistischen islamistischen Parteien
ist schon dass es sich wahrscheinlich
auch auswirken wird auf die
Minderheiten Politik auf
Meinungsfreiheit auch auf die Verfolgung
der Opposition viele Kurden haben darauf
schon reagiert weil der Innenminister
angekündigt hat er das ja nun auch gegen
sagen wir mal kurdische Anwälte vorgehen
will die in politischen Prozessen
verteidigen eine einige haben davon das
Land auch bereits verlassen also wir
werden da sicherlich sehen dass sich die
Schrauben weiter anziehen auf der
anderen Seite aber ist ein sehr
pragmatischer Politiker der eben auch
sehen muss dass die Wirtschaft schlecht
läuft dass er die Inflation sehr hoch
ist und insofern wird er jetzt versuchen
da wahrscheinlich auch Konzessionen zu
machen zu seiner Finanzpolitik ändert
also auf niedrigere Zinsen setzt um die
Inflation einzudämmen das muss man sehen
wundern würde mich das nicht denn er ist
halt ein Pragmatik und das gilt auch für
die Politik gegenüber der EU und der
NATO er hat den NATO-Beitritt Schwedens
bisher konsequent geblockt ich rechne
eher damit dass wir in den nächsten
Wochen sehen könnten das ist dann doch
im Beitrittsprozess Schwedens vorangeht
insofern denke ich mir werden wir da
auch
Zugeständnisse sehen denn erdogan ist
halt ein Pragmatiker letztlich
zum Schluss noch eine Frage aus dem
Stream an Dich von Nicole Kreischer
kommt die bei Youtube sie fragt sich
warum sagen Sie das ist noch
nationalistischer wird glaube ich nicht
sagt Nicole Kaiser jetzt beobachtest du
bist seit vielen Jahren für uns in der
Türkei natürlich auch schon lange
Erdogans Politik warum glaubst du es
wird noch nationalistischer
man muss eben mit wem er da jetzt
koaliert also wir haben da eine eine
sehr
nationalistische islamistische Partei
mit der hühnerpaar wir haben Sinan Ohren
gesehen ein eine politische Figur die
schon seit vielen Jahren in der
türkischen Polizisten unterwegs ist
ehemaliges Mitglied der
ultra-nationalistischen MHP also da
haben sich jetzt verschiedene Parteien
zusammen getan die natürlich in
politisch auch werden versuchen werden
auf Erdogan Druck auszuüben insofern
muss man mal sehen ob das jetzt auch
konsequent umgesetzt wird was aber
glaube ich ähm zu beobachten ist es dass
er gerade bei den Nachbarstaaten bei den
turkstaaten in der direkten Umgebung in
der Region viel Beifall bekommen hat die
werden sicherlich weiter zusammenrücken
Einschätzung von Jörg Brase live aus
Ankara vielen Dank ja
und wir gehen weiter in unserer Sendung
aber natürlich bleiben wir beim Thema
wir schauen gleich zusammen einen
Beitrag denn was man natürlich wissen
muss über einen Mann der seit
Jahrzehnten zwei Jahrzehnten jetzt schon
an der Macht ist er dort erdogan hat in
den letzten 20 Jahren die Türkei
umgebaut zu einem strikten
Präsidialsystem das bedeutet alle Macht
konzentriert sich auf ihn wir schauen
rein in einen Beitrag von Jochen Spieß
Präsident Recep Tayyip Erdogan hat zehn
Jahre lang einen grundlegenden Umbau der
politischen Strukturen betrieben von
einer parlamentarischen Demokratie hin
zu einem strikten Präsidialsystem der
Beginn lag in Krisenzeiten
2013 gab es größere Proteste im gesipark
von Istanbul 2016 scheiterte der
Putschversuch von Teilen des türkischen
Militärs begleitet von
Massenentlassungen und einer
Verhaftungswelle mutmaßlicher
politischer Gegner
Erdogan initiierte 2017 im offiziellen
Ausnahmezustand des Landes ein
Verfassungsreferendum
51,4% der Türkinnen und Türken stimmten
für die neue Verfassung so lautete das
amtliche Ergebnis des Referendums auch
das Parlament stimmte für die
tiefgreifenden Verfassungsänderungen die
so im Juni 2018 in Kraft traten die
Funktionen des Staats- und
Regierungschefs sind im Präsidentenamt
vereint Erdogan kann seitdem
durchregieren und eigenmächtig
Verordnungen erlassen die das Parlament
nur mit einem eigenen Gesetz wieder
aufheben kann doch der Präsident könnte
dann das Parlament auflösen und
Neuwahlen ausrufen sogar manche Richter
kann der türkische Präsident benennen
Justiz hat ihre Unabhängigkeit
weitgehend verloren die meinungs- und
pressefreiheit ist schon länger massiv
eingeschränkt die neue Verfassung gilt
seit knapp fünf Jahren der jetzige
Wahltermin wurde vorgezogen so dass
Erdogans reguläre Amtszeit noch nicht
ganz vorbei ist so sieht er sich im
Recht im neuen Präsidialsystem zum
dritten Mal zur Wahl anzutreten
eigentlich sind in der Türkei nur zwei
präsidiale Amtszeiten vorgesehen
bei uns nun Bano Güven sie ist
Journalistin aus der Türkei sie bekam
die uneingeschränkte Macht Erdogans zu
spüren sie lebt in Deutschland erstmal
schön dass Sie bei uns sind ich erkläre
gleich noch ein bisschen was über sie
hallo schönen guten Tag Frau given
guten Tag guten Tag Frau given sie leben
in Deutschland seit gegen den TV-Sender
für den Sie in der Türkei gearbeitet
haben eine Verfahren eröffnet wurde
wegen angeblicher Gefährdung der
nationalen Sicherheit und der
angeblichen Nähe zu einer
Terrororganisation sie sind uns jetzt
gerade aus Istanbul zugeschaltet aber
sie sind eben jetzt zur Wahl hin gereist
das war ihnen lange nicht möglich und
das ist für sie auch gar nicht mal so
eine ganz einfache Angelegenheit dass
sie das jetzt getan haben was war immer
die Sorge in die Türkei zu reisen für
Sie
für Journalisten die
unabhängig berichten die nicht gehorsam
sind
besteht bestehen immer Risiken hier in
der Türkei und
insbesondere wenn es um die kurdische
Frage geht
darf man dann nur sagen was Erdogan als
Präsident und seine Politik vorschreibt
Frau schreiben also deswegen haben viele
Journalisten insbesondere unsere
kurdischen Kollegen Probleme und auch
vor den Wahlen wurden viele festgenommen
inhaftiert die in der in der kurdischen
Region der Türkei berichten also für uns
ähm gehen immer wieder Beschwerden ein
und also seit zwei Jahren kann ich jetzt
weil das Verfahren das lächerliche
Verfahren
weil ich in dem lächerlichen Verfahren
würde ich sagen freigesprochen worden
bin
ich dann gekommen und seit zwei Jahren
kann ich ohnehindrüse hin und herreisen
aber das heißt nicht dass keine
Ermittlungen gegen mich laufen oder
gelaufen sind
also man muss das halt nur einsehen und
für mich ist es wichtig dass ich mich
von meinem Land von meiner Heimat nicht
löse und so ähnlich geht es auch vielen
Journalisten die mit lebenslangen
Strafen gedroht sind ja Haftstrafen
gedroht sind wieder ähm also seinen
Namen kennt man in Deutschland aber es
gibt Dutzende von Journalisten die nicht
mehr in die Türkei zurückkehren können
und in den nächsten fünf Jahren das auch
nicht machen werden wahrscheinlich genau
sie trauen sich das jetzt haben Sie uns
auch im Vorgespräch erzählt andere
trauen sich das wiederum nicht aus guten
Gründen wir hatten auch vor der Wahl in
der Sendung die sagte sie traut sich das
nicht zu einzureisen fürchtet um ihre
Sicherheit also genau diese Seite diese
Befürchtung gibt es auch was sind denn
jetzt aber ihre Sorgen nach dem Ergebnis
also was fürchten sie für ihr Heimatland
für die Türkei was kommt jetzt
in seiner
balkonrede gestern Nacht hat Erdogan
deutlich gemacht dass seine repressive
Politik dass er seine repressive Politik
und auch die Verletzungen der der rechte
Rechtsverletzungen auf die Spitze
treiben wird und das gilt auch für die
Pressefreiheit natürlich
und wir haben keine
Hoffnung dass es uns besser gehen wird
und
in bei jeder Wahl müssen wir das
wiederholen dass ohne freie Medien keine
demokratischen Wahlen stattfinden können
und
bei diesen Wahlen war das wieder der
Fall und bei den nächsten Wahlen wird es
nicht besser werden und viele
Journalisten ich habe eben erwähnt dass
kurdische Kollegen Kolleginnen verhaftet
worden sind vor den Wahlen
für sie gibt es auch keine große
Hoffnungen jetzt freigelassen zu werden
in den letzten in den nächsten Monaten
oder Jahren vielleicht auch
erdogan hat auch darauf hingewiesen z.B
als er über seine
politischen Gegner der in den bei den
Vorletzten Wahlen 6 Millionen Stimmen
bekommen hatte
redete hat hat die Masse vor ihm
entsprechend hören
Hinrichtung seine Hinrichtung gerufen
von Verlassen der Mittag und er hat
zugehört also er lässt das zu äh diese
diese Atmosphäre er möchte dass diese
Atmosphäre
durch diese Politik weiter geprägt wird
und ja es gibt
wie gesagt keine keine große Hoffnung im
Gegenteil aber man muss auch
unterstreichen dass die türkische
Gesellschaft und die Opposition und die
viele Kollegen und Kollegen auf die ich
sehr stolz bin sehr
widerstandsfähig sind man darf nie
vergessen dass knapp
25,5 Millionen Menschen sich gegen
Erdogan eräubert haben bei diesen Wahlen
und es gibt Lokal also Kommunalwahlen in
10 11 Monaten und da werden wir wieder
alles durchmachen
also mal gucken man darf nie vergessen
dass
obwohl die Mehrheit die knappe Mehrheit
Erdogan wählt eine große Masse von
demokratisch geprägten WLAN
in die entgegen sich in die
entgegenrichtung entscheiden für die
entgegenrichtung entscheiden und nicht
aufhören zu kämpfen weil wir gesehen
haben 68 Entschuldigung 86 Prozent
Wahlbeteiligung über 68
86% Wahlbeteiligung
es etwas was man nicht oft sieht in
Europa zum Beispiel das stimmt und sie
haben die widerstandsfähigen Türkinnen
und Türken angesprochen und auch
natürlich regionale Wahlen die jetzt
auch noch früher dann irgendwann folgen
werden aber wie ist zum Schluss die
Frage noch wie wie groß ist ihre
Hoffnung für eine freie
Berichterstattung dann jetzt in der
Zukunft bei nächsten Wahlen unter diesen
Umständen
also es wird nicht besser sein als heute
und es wird sogar es kann sogar
schlimmer werden wir werden nicht nur in
Medien also wie Fernsehen also Sender
TV-Sender oder Zeitungen sondern auch in
social Medien werden wir
Schwierigkeiten haben
einige einige Accounts wurden mussten
von Twitter eingefroren werden z.B vor
der vor dem ersten Wahlgang weil die
Regierung die diese Plattform damit
bedroht sie zu beschließen oder ihre
Bandweite zu verringern und also das ist
gar keine demokratische atmosphärisch
hier und wie wie demokratisch können
Wahlen sein wenn
das der Zustand ist
also können Sie sich vorstellen dass in
einer in
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien die
Opposition nur
36 Minuten
reden konnte für höchstens 40 Minuten
reden durfte wobei Erdogan für
über 36 Stunden Zeit hatte
sein Propaganda zu machen also das sind
Sachen also ist es liegt natürlich nicht
nur an den Medien dieses Ergebnis es
gibt auch andere
Gründe warum Menschen Erdogan lieben und
wählen und drüber habt ihr auch mit dir
gesprochen also national stolz und die
Herausforderung an den Westen
und diese
dieses Gefühl von einer Bedrohung von
Westen von
Terrororganisationen und so weiter
da fallen auf diese auf diese
Vorwürfe würde ich sagen fallen die
Erdogan Wähler herein immer wieder und
auch auf sein Versprechen egal wie
schlimm die wirtschaftliche Lage ist
egal wie groß die Abwertung des
Türkischen Lira ist sie fallen auch
herein drauf herein wenn er sagt dass er
die Löhne erhöhen wird und so weiter
aber also die die Wähler von Erdogan
Leben in dem Moment und sie sie sind
immer noch nicht bewusst was für eine
Last und Schulden und was für eine
Zukunft sie ihren Enkeln
lassen werden
das sagt die Journalistin Banu Güven die
uns aus Istanbul zugeschaltet war vielen
Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast waren
heute Frau Güven vielen Dank für die
Einladung danke wir wollen jetzt in der
Sendung auch noch mal insbesondere
vertiefen die Verbindung natürlich
zwischen der Türkei und der EU und dem
Westen also das soll jetzt bei uns Thema
sein denn eine Sache wir haben es am
Anfang der Sendung schon angesprochen
die für uns natürlich auch interessant
ist wie hoch die Zustimmung für ihn hier
bei uns in Deutschland ist wir sehen
jetzt Bilder denn nachdem klar war dass
Erdogan gewonnen hat gab es nicht nur in
der Türkei großen Jubel sondern eben
auch hier bei uns in Deutschland Erdogan
Fans feierten hier in Hamburg wie wir
sehen können aber auch in Berlin
Frankfurt am Main Duisburg in vielen
Orten in ganz Deutschland das wollen wir
jetzt auch noch mal eingehender
besprechen und wir haben uns jetzt zum
Schluss noch einen Gast eingeladen es
ist zahnaver ist vom Zentrum für Türkei
Studien und integrationsforschung und
jetzt bei uns schönen guten Tag Herr
wäre
wir können jetzt mit ihnen auch hier
über dieses Ergebnis bei uns in
Deutschland sprechen denn in Deutschland
kurz mal ein paar Zahlen hätten rund 1,5
Millionen Türken und Türken wählen
können rund 50% haben das dann auch
getan die Frage vielleicht mal an Sie
zum Anfang was wäre denn wenn die andere
Hälfte auch gewählt hätte wäre das dann
auch so ganz klar eindeutig für erdogan
ist das einfach so dass das Menschen
hier bei uns in Deutschland mehr zu
Erdogan tendieren tatsächlich
nun über das Wahlverhalten der
Nichtwähler gibt es keine Erkenntnis
insofern wäre es eigentlich eher
spekulativ darüber zu berichten aber ich
glaube auch wenn wir die Wahl
Beteiligung unter den Deutsch Türken
hier in Deutschland erhöhen würden oder
wenn sie gestiegen wäre würde das ja am
Endergebnis vermutlich nicht sehr viel
ausmachen wir haben in Deutschland nun
mal geprägt auch durch die Gastarbeiter
Migration ein eher konservativ religiös
oder nationalistisch orientiertes Milieu
wo diese Werte auch über die Generation
hinweg vererbt werden insofern ist
bleibt dieses Milieu quasi auch bestehen
es war ja jetzt am Ende ein Rennen 52
rund 52 % für Erdogan damit hat er
gewonnen 48 % für den Herausforderer
haben die deutschen Stimmen jetzt bei
der Stichwahl in diesem engen Rennen
denn wirklich auch ein Unterschied
gemacht würden Sie sagen nein erdogan
hat mit gut 2,3 Millionen Stimmen
Vorsprung die Wahl gewonnen die Stimmen
aus Deutschland
machen rund 700.000 aus die auf beide
Kandidaten verteilt werden insofern sind
weder die deutschen Stimmen als auch die
Stimmen international es werden ja auch
in mehreren Staaten gewählt weltweit
haben nicht den Einfluss auf das aber
haben nicht dazu geführt dass Erdogan
den den warzig errungen konnte sie haben
gesagt spekulativ über die zu sprechen
die nicht gewählt haben darüber haben
wir keine Erkenntnis aber lassen Sie uns
sprechen über die die gewählt haben und
da in Deutschland eben mehrheitlich für
Erdogan gestimmt haben gibt es
Erkenntnisse darüber warum jetzt die
Türkinnen und Türken in Deutschland
mehrheitlich eben zur Erdogan tendieren
nur diese Wahl war dominiert von der ist
ja auch gerade im Beitrag der Antwort
genannt worden von Sicherheit und äh
Identität Aspekten Identität da ging es
mehr um nationalistische stimmen dass
nationalistische Milieu zu mobilisieren
mit der Religion da sind eben Menschen
die religiös sind darunter auch
todesständige auch in den südöstlichen
Landesteilen unmittelbar angesprochen
worden und die Sicherheit zu
gewährleisten haben sowohl Türken in der
Türkei als auch ein Großteil der
Wahlberechtigten im Ausland Erdogan eher
zugemutet und nicht der Opposition
weshalb sie dann ihn gewählt haben dann
gibt es eben diese Milieu Verbundenheit
das sind Menschen die aus gradierten
konservativen religiösen Videos gekommen
sind und über die Generationen hinweg
die Werte auch größtenteils
weitervererbt werden die Tatsache dass
die Türkei unter der unter Erdogans
Regierung die Modernisierung und auch
die wohlstandsentwicklungen aus ihrer
Sicht und auch im Vergleich zu den
Vorgängerregierung vor 2002 sehen sind
Aspekte ihn zu wählen Stichwort regional
macht ist ein Thema wo sie auch stolz
sein können auf ihre Herkunftsland dann
kommen wir auch zum nächsten Punkt
nämlich die doppelte Benachteiligung
religiöses Milieu in der Türkei sind bis
2002 also Kopftuchverbot
ausgegrenzt gewesen zumindest Teile
dieser Bevölkerung und in Deutschland
hatten auch
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
Gastarbeiter und deren Nachkommen auch
die ausgrenzungserfahrung weshalb eben
diese doppelte Benachteiligung gewisse
emotionale Lücken aufgeschlossen hat die
Erdogan sehr gut wusste zu füllen und
dann haben wir auch einen mediendominanz
eine sehr starke mediendominanz die auch
gerade im Beitrag auch genannt worden
ist worüber auch die Menschen in der
Türkei aber auch im Ausland angesprochen
werden das heißt der die Regierung
dominiert eigentlich so die
Meinungsbildung über die Medien aber
auch die staatlichen Strukturen die ist
in Deutschland gibt über die oder
Parteistrukturen über die dann die
Regierung Einfluss übt auch die AKP
beispielsweise Ableger Organisationen in
Deutschland die über mehr Ressourcen
verfügen wegen der staatlichen Nähe als
die Opposition sind Aspekte warum auch
hier in Deutschland
Erdogan und die AKP gewonnen haben an
dieser Stelle gesagt dass wir in dieser
Sendung auch gerne mit einem Erdogan
Wähler sprechen wollten der uns aber
sehr kurzfristig heute Nacht abgesagt
hat also gab da bestimmt auch ganz
spannende Fragen die wir ihm hätten
stellen können also jetzt aber zu eben
den Fragen aus dem Stream ich habe hier
eine von einem User an der Userin nennt
er oder sie sich und zwar ist die Frage
bedeutet ein Ja zur Erdogan nicht auch
gleichzeitig eine Verletzung der eigenen
Integrität als Bundesbürger im Hinblick
auf die zwei Drittel der Deutsch-Türken
die Erdogan gewählt haben was würden Sie
sagen
ist durchaus berechtigt und diese Frage
wird auch in Zukunft auch viel stärker
in der Öffentlichkeit aber auch in der
politischen Bildung diskutiert werden
müssen was heißt das
jetzt höre ich zumindest Herr A werden
nicht mehr eingefrorenes Bild und er ist
auch immer noch eingefroren in der
Hoffnung dass wir das reparieren können
ich warte da mal auf eine Information
oder wir warten gemeinsam bisher aber
wieder sehen das gibt mir aber kurz Zeit
hier auch noch mal in Eure Kommentare zu
schauen und zwar
sehe ich hier einen Kommentar ist aber
auch gleichzeitig mit einer Frage
verbunden von BA er schreibt immer wenn
es um die Türkei geht verhält sich Cem
Özdemir sehr und demokratisch die
Menschen in Deutschland haben in einer
freien Wahl gewählt das sollte auch mir
respektieren ich hatte am Anfang der
Sendung auch angesprochen dass der
bundesagenminister gesagt hat hatte dass
würden wir sehr gerne gleich auch mit
Herrn aber weiter besprechen
es sei denn wieder bei uns ich glaube
das dauert noch einen Moment höre ich
gerade bis wir die Leitung wieder da
haben für alle die jetzt erst
eingeschaltet haben würden wir jetzt
noch einmal zusammen schauen auf einen
Beitrag aus der Nacht aber das können
wir uns auch sparen höre ich gerade weil
er aber ist wieder da Das ist doch ganz
fantastisch ja aber sie können mich
wieder hören und vielleicht auch gleich
sehen wir sie
gleich ist er wieder da gut also wir
haben Fragen gesammelt ich fasse noch
mal kurz zusammen wir wollen die Frage
von User Userin BA bei Youtube stellen
Herr aber ist wieder da war aber
eigentlich gerade mitten im Satz
unterbrochen sie hatten ja gerade noch
auf eine user-frage geantwortet da geht
es um die Integrität als bundesürer
wollen sie da uns noch mal kurz ihre
knappe Antwort liefern dass wir die
nicht verpassen jetzt ja also dieses
transformationale Leben was wir hier
Integrationspolitik auch als mehr als
ein Mehrwert verstehen bringt natürlich
auch eine gewisse Verantwortung nämlich
über das Wahlverhalten in diesem
konkreten Fall was es bedeutet im
Herkunftsland ein autoritäres System zu
unterstützen und selbst in einer
Demokratie zu leben und das
Wahlverhalten dieser Gruppe
ignoriert in der Regel auch die
Demokratie Defizite die end
Demokratisierung in der Türkei weshalb
ist tatsächlich auch hier geboten sein
wird zukünftig auch über dieses Thema
viel stärker zu diskutieren in der
politischen Bildung in der
Öffentlichkeit als es bisher der Fall
war
dann hatte ich eben noch einen weiteren
Kommentar in bei uns im Chat bei Youtube
gesehen und zwar ging es darum die
Aussage von bundesagraminister Özdemir
ich würde das noch mal kurz für alle
wiederholen er sagte nämlich über diese
Freuden feiern und autokorses in
deutschen Städten sie sind eine nicht zu
überhörende Absage an unsere
pluralistische Demokratie und Zeugnis
unseres Scheiterns unter ihnen und
daraufhin gab es einen Kommentar bei uns
bei Youtube und zwar schrieb hier BA
immer wenn es um die Türkei geht verhält
sich Cem Özdemir sehr undemokratisch die
Menschen in Deutschland haben in einer
freien Wahl gewählt das sollte auch
Champ Özdemir respektieren er aber wir
stehen sie zu diesen beiden Aussagen
einmal die das Users der Userin und
einmal die von Jim Özdemir
grundsätzlich gesehen ist es richtig sie
haben an einer demokratischen Wahl
teilgenommen haben auch die Grundrecht
von ihrem Grundrecht Gebrauch gemacht
das bedeutet aber nicht dass sie wahllos
oder bzw unkommentiert belassen können
ihr Wahlverhalten diese Wahlverhalten
wird Fragen auf über die auch diskutiert
werden muss und das erleben wir in den
letzten Jahren dass eben wie gesagt die
end Demokratisierung quasi dem Wohlstand
der identitätszugehörigkeit
untergeordnet wird was er als abstrakt
verstanden wird weil sie auch von diesen
Folgen der Demokratisierung selbst
nichts spüren insofern wird man eben
dieses Thema zukünftig viel stärker
diskutiert werden müssen gehen wir noch
auf eine weitere Reaktion eines unseres
Bundeskanzlers nicht nur eines
Bundespolitiker sondern unseres Kanzlers
ein der gratulierte nämlich Erdogan bei
Twitter er schrieb Deutschland und die
Türkei sind enge Partner und alliierte
auch gesellschaftlich und wirtschaftlich
sind wir stark miteinander verbunden nun
wollen wir unsere gemeinsamen Themen mit
frischen Elan vorantreiben
und lässt sich mit Erdogan künftig
zusammenarbeiten was ist ihre
Einschätzung nun an den bisherigen
bilateralen Beziehungen wird sich
wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel ändern
vermutlich wird es sogar noch zu einer
Entspannungspolitik führen weil die wird
drohende Wirtschafts- und Finanzkrise in
der Türkei gute Beziehungen zu
westlichen Partnern erfordert weil
Investitionen notwendig sind
insofern glaube ich schon dass Erdogan
jetzt in seiner letzten Amtszeit wo er
auch keine Wiederwahl mehr befürchten
muss
durchaus ein Stück weit persönlichere
Töne einschlagen wird um insbesondere
die wirtschaftliche Lage im Land zu
stabilisieren und ähm den Lehrer Abfall
beispielsweise zu stoppen insofern
glaube ich schon das heißt aber nicht
dass innerhalb der Türkei also in
politisch eine Demokratisierung damit
einhergehen wird und schauen wir auch
noch mal eben auf die Verbindung auf die
Beziehung zu Europa zur EU denn der
Vorsitzende der Europäischen Volkspartei
EVP Manfred Weber der forderte den EU
-beitrittsprozess mit der Türkei zu
beenden wäre das für Sie der richtige
Weg
nun eine Beendigung der Beziehungen also
der des Beitrittsprozesses würde von
beiden Seiten
politisch instrumentalisiert werden
insofern glaube ich nicht dass der
ohnehin schon faktisch beendete oder
ruhiggestellt Beitritt Prozent
aufgegriffen werden wird die Türkei wird
die den Prozess nicht beenden ich glaube
aber auch nicht dass die Europäische
Union das beenden wird vielleicht wird
man es aussetzen und das offiziell
benennen aber faktisch gesehen wird
findet seit Jahren ohnehin kein kein
keine Verhandlungen statt in diesen
Richtung aber heißt das auch
gleichzeitig ist wird jetzt zu oder
grundsätzlich die Beziehungen sind nicht
gut bleiben schlecht jetzt mit der EU
oder sehen Sie da auch irgendwie
Hoffnung auf eine gute Zusammenarbeit in
den nächsten fünf Jahren ich glaube
schon ich glaube beispielsweise das was
die NATO Erweiterung mit Schweden angeht
das Schweden bald Mitglied werden wird
und die Türkei ihre Blockade aufheben
wird in Bezug auf das
flüchtlingsabkommen hat er dann selber
gesagt treu zu bleiben diesen Abkommen
gegenüber im gegen Zug erhofft sich er
natürlich auch westliche Investitionen
in der Türkei insofern auch der
Wirtschaft und sicherheitspolitischen
Ebene glaube ich schon das ist dort
Annäherungen geben wird aber in Bezug
auf die auf dem Beitritt Prozent oder
auch in den bilateralen Beziehung mit
Deutschland wo Menschenrechtsfragen ganz
oben auf der Agenda stehen werden sich
keine großeartigen positiven
Veränderungen ergeben so dass man eben
mit dem Status Quo weiter arbeiten
werden muss
die Einschätzung von charner aber vom
Zentrum für türkei-studien und
integrationsforschung vielen Dank dass
Sie bei uns zu Gast waren
und damit wenn wir jetzt auch am Ende
von unserer Sendung ich hoffe ihr
konntet bisschen was mitnehmen ich hoffe
ich konnte viele eurer Fragen hier auch
beantworten und jetzt sagen wir erstmal
vielen Dank und viele von euch haben
hoffentlich einen schönen freien Tag und
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss